um with everything that's going on
you guys are kind of like the hot hot
topic of the internet there's like
documentaries about you and what's
happened to your family and
you know your brothers that have been
been been taken and
you know there's like one that's got
like five million views on youtube it's
it's like it's like a whole you know
you've probably seen him yeah i ran
across it but
see all this [ __ ] just be like i said it
just be for the hype you know what i'm
saying
so i don't really like it just be
putting stuff together it'd be outside
people looking in
i was gonna say but like is that is that
like an interesting position to be in
where you're like there's like
youtubers making full-fledged 30-minute
documentaries about your
trauma your life you know what i'm
saying it's really bad
i don't really like when they do stuff
like that because now i make the
industry look at me in certain ways
not they feel like they can't have me in
certain places
because of violence you know what i'm
saying and that ain't what i'm trying to
give out like you feel i'm saying
that's like feminine i'm mature i'm
wrong so i'm trying to really like
listen
let's let's get you feel me yeah i want
this money let's let's
let's i want greatness i want grammys
and i want all this
see all that you can't get all that when
you got violence with
when you got when you're surrounded by
violence they don't want that
to be fair your biggest song is an
extremely
negative diss record for sure it's it's
one of the most ruthless dis records in
hip-hop history
for sure it's top two the other one's
the other guy's one that he put out
so like it's crazy like to be fair do
you think like like when you say like
it's is people
look at you and they think of that like
are they wrong to think of that right
now because that's kind of like
that's that's their fault that's fair
because they don't they
don't like they just see that one record
and then i got so much music like no you
got catalog you know what i'm saying so
it's i got so much great music for sure
stuff that i've not been stood up 10
hours a day every day and i've been
saying like you you're not new
this is not like you didn't just come on
the scene you've been doing your thing
you've been putting
i just be dissing i don't know that i
ain't even me to even do that i don't
even like stuff
i don't like i said i don't even like
the internet i don't even play the
internet role i only like going back and
forth
with people right right right this ain't
this hanging in that field i'm saying
so i'd just be what do you think is the
biggest misconception about young and
ace
yeah but here it's a lot of [ __ ] that
people be missing
like what they miss misunderstood you
know what i'm saying
like i be feeling like people be trying
to block me out because of certain [ __ ]
like if i'm saying
i'm gonna go for real for sure like you
know what i'm saying like she's so crazy
because my life
is real life so that's why everybody
grabbing gravitating toward this
like this real life this thing he ain't
just you know what i'm saying so that's
what making it like
you know what i'm saying the way they
shaking it up like i banged me yeah
you're good but it's shaking
like shaking stuff up i'm underrating on
the goat for sure
i'll be i'm trying to open everybody's
eyes now you just i need people to open
their eyes and really see what's going
on but really i really been trying to
help people mm-hmm
that's that's one thing about me i'm i'm
always helpful i've always been helpful
even when nobody will help me i want to
see everybody win i ain't no
crap what i'm saying see my city full of
crabs in the pot i ain't the crowd
i never got in that part where the crabs
was you know what i'm saying so
just sit like that like one thing they
i want the best for everybody